hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to one night at
flumpty's - now I'm playing this
immediately after I played to over easy
mode and I wanted to see how hard-boiled
mode was gonna be and if it was gonna be
as intense and death-defying as I think
it's gonna be because probably will be
and I'm probably gonna fail a lot and
I'm probably gonna die over and over it
over and over and over again
but I know all the rules so I don't know
how much harder it could be oh the owl
is already active okay so I know the
basic rules so this is gonna take a
while
[ __ ] god dammit I'm [ __ ] up already
piece of [ __ ] that I am is boned and I'm
going to die just like this says here
alright so I just got to be mindful of
everything and know that things are
gonna be way more active than they
usually is including flumpty you
supposed to be mysteriously absent from
all my cameras oh no he's not he's in
the other room over there okay so I knew
oh [ __ ] already Jesus alright fine his
patience meter starts out a little lower
that's fine though that happened Oh
cameras or events okay god there's so
much to keep track of this is gonna be a
frantic night I'm friggin out oh [ __ ] yo
why you Jesus and I don't know what was
with like the broken eggshell if that
was actually meaning anything or if that
was gonna just do nothing
patients about to run out anybody else
on the way nope time for you trying to
win a game here anybody he's almost on
the way in oh he's out okay so oh okay
that was already goddamnit I think that
the dude the red dude
Oh time that well you son of a [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] don't ah [ __ ]
that's a lot of exposure brah that's a
lot of exposure yeah okay so basically
I'm bone this is what this is a whole
battle that son of a [ __ ] how did that
run out so quickly I wasn't even in this
isn't even in the general area of what
those could be flumpty thank you he's
wandered in the flumpty's are not
patients about to run out patients hey
the triple shot alright go away now
please thank you oh man that's really
cool like they built in a they built in
animations to this sumbitch to actually
make it work with everything okay so the
patience is good since it's fine
Lumpy's over there do that cuz it's
easier for me if camera 5:1 that I'm
gonna watch out for otherwise okay so I
gotta let that charge a bit I got four
point seven on the thing don't ask me
what that means cuz I don't know he's a
coming in I just so happened to close
the correct one oh this
Oh God Oh
[Music]
however this game is gonna be it like
[Applause]
here's your friend is a little late you
just miss flumpty how's it going there
[Music]
it's like not on my instinct to check
that okay I didn't think of the patience
guy he [ __ ] God thank you please keep
bashing on that one I knew he was coming
I just accidentally checks for another
thing yes you go away now
patience is fine okay we're fine we're
fine we're fine staying on top of things
okay hi sorry I was in the middle of
something I was rubbing my eye sorry I I
can't pay that much attention to you I
know you want me senpai to notice you
but please I'm busy I'm a busy man
please stand by please oh [ __ ]
hi herb oh there's the burb thank you I
was wondering where the perb was you
know yeah thank you
in fact for coming when I needed you to
be here and not what I didn't because
[ __ ] you three seconds or not three
seconds three whatever the unit of time
that [ __ ] is
[Music]
[ __ ] god damned of course just as I do
that
yes son of a [ __ ] cats cats cats cats
everybody at once tense tense tense
tense tense eat it seeped into tits tits
tits [ __ ] where's red with red with red
zones wait I didn't have enough I I got
too much exposure for that one anyway
too early in the night because of
[ __ ] 20 B nasties but god dammit god
dammit why does the light switch have to
be close to the goddamn camera area I
can't do things quickly wondering where
he was
oh come on now that's [ __ ]
I was checking not too soon it's been
long time I'm gonna keep this off thank
you
thank you that's why I'm gonna keep and
that's why I'm gonna keep it off but
that means the birds probably can kill
me Amy probably yep oh can I can I pull
this off perfectly is the good question
that everybody's asking me no of course
not I'm markiplier I'm gonna find a way
to screw it up in the worst way possible
oh boy yes I am yes I am
oh [ __ ] this is the worst way possible
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay it's okay
I wasn't paying attention
oh I didn't even look at the time for
the clown probably cuz there are so few
numbers left that it was [ __ ] up
damn it whoa damn it damn it I
accidentally clicked
I didn't mean to click but I
accidentally well that was stupid anyway
because I was gonna die because I got
screwed over by a stupid
I had a stupid and it's stupid [ __ ] god
damn it I am 1 miss click on the big red
meat eat your nuts I was gonna win I was
gonna win I was gonna win
[ __ ] I had it in the bag and then I got
flumpty my I got flumpty fingers my
fingers went off flumpty [ __ ] I knew it
I knew red was coming I knew red was
comin why didn't I wait [ __ ] damn it I'm
gettin good but stupid mistakes are
gonna cost me
[Music]
I did it god damn that ha ha ha oh man
kidnap person wins flumpty bumpty x'
game after countless citizens of new
dork have been deducted by the mystery
of flumpty bumpty play survival haaziq
game one is beds it's lumpy and friendly
become the Romney new best friend Wade
alleged leaf lovely is contracted as
skinless many-headed monster out of the
corpses of his games unfortunate past
content did someone on blur all the rest
of that stuff but yes oh man it just
feels good to finally beat it because
that one took an hour and 40 minutes to
be not as bad as like the five nights at
Freddy's 20 modes but still goddamn yes
yes yes yes hey the way that was one
night at flumpty's to beaten to
completion beaten on the hardest mode
ever I went through that last
playthrough completely silent and I did
it very well like once you understand
the pattern and that's what I like about
this game it's very difficult but
nothing is unfair everything is as it
should be even like if everything times
itself on top of each other if you have
the right strategy which I did and I
refined it you just don't need to make a
mistake so long as you don't make a
mistake he got it done is there anything
else after this okay so that's gonna
fade out it's probably gonna go back
menu yeah I got a star it's just one
star this time but either way I get it
everybody it took me an hour and 40
minutes but I did it so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to check out the 20/20 modes that I
did on five nights at Freddy's one two
and three
you can check them out through the link
in the description below or in the
annotation over there thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh